i am not surprised to see the end of
trump's at least first four years ending
chaotically
since that is how they began and that is
how they went and that is why he was
elected in the first place to be a
disrupter
so why are people so shocked that he
continues to disrupt
all right this is the reuben report i'm
dave rubin and we are doing a quick
on the fly interview today because i
mentioned on the show the other day i
don't know who to trust anymore i don't
know who's making sense
i don't know who's looking at the world
with clear eyes and i went through my
mental rolodex
and megyn kelly popped up and megan you
agreed to do the show
just like that and here we are how you
doing
i'm doing well for you dave anytime
clear eyes
full heart can't lose all right well
here are my notes for today's
interview oh and you're just like
me pony i got nothing although my guys
did tell me this is this is gonna air on
sunday we're taping this friday
afternoon so people will have to bear
with
you know if any little crazy vote got
changed or anything else but
generally speaking as we tape this on
friday afternoon
how are you feeling about the state of
this election
the media portion of it the recount
portion of it
biden trump the whole damn thing
i have a lot of thoughts um a lot of
thoughts let's do them let's do them one
at a time
i am not surprised to see the end of
trump's at least first four years ending
chaotically
since that is how they began and that is
how they went and that is why he was
elected in the first place to be a
disrupter
so why are people so shocked that he
continues to disrupt
uh right up to the last what appear to
be the last final moments of
you know his his if not his presidency
his you know the time
in his presidency before election um i
think trump has lost
i do i know people don't want to hear
that um but i think he's lost
and i think a lot of people are
struggling to
accept it right it's like a grief
process the first
first step is denial and i think
trump i'm not saying that he shouldn't
get we should do all the stuff we should
we should check out what's happening in
pennsylvania he should see those legal
challenges through we should make sure
we have a
wisconsin recount a georgia recount but
my
assessment from where i set out here is
there are not enough
gettable votes even if he can prove
fraud or some untoward process with the
mail-in votes
to get him over the top anymore if that
that phase has passed
do you have do you have faith that the
numbers that we're getting
are real like do you have faith that not
only the people on the ground in
whatever state you want to pick whatever
city you want to
uh pick are are being honest and that is
being translated to us honestly through
the media do you have faith in that
not utter faith but enough faith i mean
these are the same people who did the
count four years ago
and he won so let's let's be real
they didn't just become fraudulent uh
you know vote counters in the past four
years and they
also hated him four years ago
it's not like they loved him they
thought he was gonna be full of love and
rainbows when he got into office
they wanted to kill him four years ago
and you know philadelphia is famous for
its voter fraud and so like these
these problems have existed long before
now
and what i'm seeing in the electoral
process is it to me it's akin to
like when we went hd and television
where everything looked just fine when
it was like there's a little fuzzy and
then like when you could see it up close
and personal it was like my eyes
like oh my god i didn't want to see this
it's hideous
and that's what's happening with our
electoral process it isn't perfect it's
far from perfect
it's the best we have should we do
better can we do better yes and yes
hello florida let's just be like florida
um but we're not right now and we're not
going to get it to the point of
ah now it's perfect and we can perfectly
know that every vote that was proper was
counted and everyone that wasn't
was not it's not going to happen people
that's not the way our system is built
so we're gonna have to do good enough
that's how the system's set up
and the even the votes he's counting
even the ones he's like that was
fraudulently filled out or that's
you're talking about handfuls handfuls
here and there you know you're not
talking
about 70 000 votes that's going to get
him over the top in arizona
that's not going to happen and you know
the places where it's tightest
biden is ahead biden is ahead right now
and george a biden is ahead
um in a couple of these states that
trump is contesting so
i just think the odds of trump turning
this around
right now are infinitesimal and so we
i'm not saying it's totally impossible
but realistically if you want to know
what i think
i think he's lost and i don't think his
legal challenges or the recounts are
going to amount to much
yeah so so what do you think he'll do do
you think he just runs the table with
every legal recap
every every legal course of action and
just does absolutely anything or do you
sense that maybe at some point if what
you're saying is right
that he will throw in the towel i know
throwing in the towel doesn't sound like
trump
and uh i also think he owes it to his
supporters who love him and
and don't trust these systems for good
reasons
to see these challenges through i have
no problem with him stoking those fires
and getting in there and making sure
to the extent he can maybe it's his
final act as president right before his
lame duck period
to like disrupt yet another system to
upend it
blow it up and ultimately make it better
right tear it down so we can come back
better for the next four year period
um but i i support his his willingness
to challenge
these you know where he has good faith
evidence
of a problem like what happened in
pennsylvania with allowing
the mail-in votes to be postmarked on
election day something that was approved
by
judges and not legislators which is not
okay
and the court refused to take that
challenge they said get back to us if
this becomes an ongoing problem after
the election
and if there's a split in the states
that we might have to resolve he should
proceed pursue that he should
but again it doesn't look like there are
enough votes in that pile
that could help him anyway i think he
should see it through i don't think he
should give
up before he has to but i think
realistically when it becomes clear that
he's lost we're gonna need
the people who are closest to him who he
trusts not the
media which he doesn't for good reason
to sit him down and say
it's no longer about you this is about
the country
and there will be a peaceful transfer of
power
and while you can go out there and say i
have real problems with the way the
system
conducted itself and i don't know about
this vote i
am going to pass the torch and put
america first
to quote somebody we all know do you
think
that part of his calculation of of even
if he
sees it that he's lost like the
challenges aren't going anywhere that
part of it will be the burn it down
thing
because you know even just a few minutes
before we started here i saw a tweet by
aoc and you know
in effect you know we're going to have
to come for trump and you know they keep
saying enablers
and the sycophants and whatever and it's
like you know a few weeks ago robert
rice who was in the clinton
administration talking about a truth and
reconciliation commission
and that these people love lists and all
of these weird things and it's like for
all the chance of locker up
it never happened there was no there was
nobody knocking on hillary's door and
that trump may feel
and i think actually for good reason
that that these people
whether the guy did anything illegal or
not they've created this monster
in their heads let's say and that they
will do things that are unimaginable
in in the american political landscape
well
i think yes they will it's not paranoia
when they really are out to get you
and that explains a lot of trump's
behavior i mean i think
the media is like so disgusted by his
rhetoric from the white house and
like it's not great i'm not going to
defend it but i understand where he's
coming from
they have been out to get him for more
than four years
the media is his enemy they
absolutely are his enemy and the
democrats
loathe him in a special way
and one does have to wonder if a lot of
these democrats think
the ends justify the means i mean that
we we really have had a baseless attempt
to
impeach the guy that was right on the
heels of a completely
made-up russia investigation and not to
mention all the
non-controversies the media fed off of
for the last four years
so he is right to totally distrust them
the pollsters have had it totally wrong
when it comes to trump all along
i do want to make a distinction between
the pollsters who predict vote
prior to the vote and the people at the
decision desks
who analyze for a living raw vote
tallies
two totally different animals okay so
just because we don't trust the
pollsters like nate silver
doesn't mean we shouldn't trust the fox
news decision desk but anyway trump
has a general distrust of these systems
that's well-founded
and so and so do his fans and that's why
i think people aren't being nuts right
now it's not crazy conspiratorial people
like knowing but
it's based on data it's based on
experience
and and to expect the left to understand
any of that
is too much to expect they won't there
isn't grace on the other side i mean
there's there's great guys like andrew
yang right who's saying all the right
things like be cool and like let's not
go too far
and whatever and then there's just jerks
like aoc you know or nancy pelosi coming
out and saying we have a mandate which
you don't even have close to amanda
and one other point on her the more you
say you have a mandate which you clearly
do not you lost house seats instead of
gaining them it looks like you're not
going to have control of the senate
you didn't get the blue wave at the
federal at the presidential level
the the more the republicans if they do
take over that senate are going to do to
stymie
every piece of joe biden's agenda there
will be no grace
on their side either if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about the media instead of
non-stop yelling check out our media
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out the full episode playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell